good evening ladies and gentlemen and
good evening to to our online audience
we're here this evening to debate a
topic which has already been much in the
news this week with the publication
yesterday of a paper by the center for
policy studies but then it's a topic
which is rarely far from the headlines
and which regularly divides opinion that
of assisted suicide the motion this
evening is assisted suicide should be
legalized the terminally ill should have
the legal right to be helped to end
their lives we have six speakers three
four and three against for the motion
are emily jackson a professor of law
debbie purdy who has ms and has
successfully campaigned to have the law
clarified on assisted suicide mary
warnock the moral philosopher and former
member of the house of lords select
committee on euthanasia and against we
have alex carlisle qc lib dem peer and
joint chair of a think tank on living
and dying well we have paddy stone next
to him who's a senior lecturer in
palliative medicine at st george's
university of london and at the end
there richard harry's lord harry's
former bishop of oxford whose latest
latest book deals with questions of life
and death you've already been asked for
your view as you came in and i'll be
giving you the result of that entrance
poll after we've heard the main speakers
our six main speakers and then i'll open
up the debate to the floor and as the
speakers sum up towards the end i'll ask
you to vote again by tearing your ticket
in half and and handing it in for or
against and then we'll give you
the the full result and we'll see any
swing that may have occurred at the very
end each speaker has up to nine minutes
to make his or her case
i've got a stopwatch somewhere
i'll get it out in a minute but i'm
going to introduce you to our first
speaker to propose the motion she's
emily jackson professor of law at the
lse her special interests are in
reproductive and end-of-life issues and
she's currently writing the in favor
half of a book called debating
euthanasia so her arguments are no doubt
well-honed emily jackson
[Applause]
thank you sue and thank you for the very
kind invitation to talk to you this
evening
i'm speaking here in favor of the
legalization of assisted suicide but i
think it's really important to clarify
exactly what i'm for in this context i
am certainly not for immediate access to
assisted suicide on demand
my argument is a much more modest one
i believe that we owe it to people who
experience unbelievable and irreversible
suffering and importantly also to those
who worry that this lies ahead of them
to do all that we can to alleviate their
fear and distress
now this is not an argument in favor of
death on the contrary i think an
effective assisted dying law could
extend and enhance the lives of people
currently facing the prospect of a
prolonged and distressing decline now
what do i mean by that
currently in the uk
patients whose fear of dying is
overwhelming can if they can afford it
and are well enough to travel visit the
dignitas clinic in jury or if they're
fit enough they can kill themselves
before they become incapacitated
now in both cases this means they die
sooner than they would if they had
access to assisted dying in the uk
and it inevitably means that they don't
have some of the most basic components
of what we might call a good death being
at home
with people you love most around you if
you go to dignitas you're in a clinic in
zurich very far from home and often far
from some of the people you most care
about if you kill yourself you may feel
the need to do so alone in order to
avoid incriminating your family or
friends
an effective assistant dying law could
also enhance the lives of the dying
because
it's reassuring
to a much wider section of society that
would ever in fact access it there was a
recent study of patients requesting
euthanasia in the netherlands and it
found that the vast majority did not at
that time want to die what they wanted
was an insurance policy against future
suffering
fewer than nine percent of the people
who initiate requests for euthanasia and
assisted suicide in netherlands die as a
result
what the evidence shows is the existence
of legalized assisted dying provides
reassurance to people
it in fact appears to enhance their
ability to tolerate the present burdens
of treatment so it's the prospect of
being able to maintain control and
autonomy at the end of life which is a
value to many many more people
than would ever actually opt for an
assisted death
it's also really important to note at
the outset that there's a really
critical difference between my position
and that of the opponents of this motion
because i agree with them that a life
which is full of suffering could
nevertheless have tremendous meaning and
value
they would clearly not seek an assisted
death for themselves and that's a
decision which i both respect and admire
but having seen people suffer at the end
of their lives i'm fairly sure though
nobody can ever be completely sure that
i would not want to continue living once
life has permanently lost any meaning
for me yet the opponents of this
motion's view is that i must endure a
dying process which fills me with horror
now in a liberal society where we accept
that people's fundamental moral values
differ we should strive as far as
possible to ensure that people like the
opponents of this motion and those of us
in favor can co-exist without any of us
forcing our values upon anyone else so i
wouldn't force a sister death upon them
but they would force me to endure a
death which i would find intolerable
so the starting point really is that
there is among a subset of patients
suffering from conditions like cancer
and motor neurone disease a strong and
understandable desire for more control
over the dying process that lies ahead
of them
now it's often suggested that palliative
care is a much better solution to the
problems faced by these people than
helping them to die
and it's undoubtedly true that
palliative medicine specialists are now
really very well equipped to manage pain
inadequate pain management for most
people ought to be a thing of the past
but the evidence suggests that what
people fear most towards the end of life
is seldom pain
the surveys from oregon and the
netherlands consistently show that
people's principal motivations for
seeking assisted death relate to loss of
autonomy cited by 97 in oregon in 2009
loss of dignity cited by 92 percent
and loss of the ability to do the things
that make life enjoyable which was 86
inadequate pain control or fear of it
was cited by only 10
it's also important to be absolutely
clear that not everyone experiences the
loss of control that prompts some
patients requests for assisted dying as
intolerably distressing
some people who are profoundly
incapacitated and dependent
gain considerable meaning and value from
their lives and they deserve to be
treated with the utmost respect
my point is that it's the patient him or
herself who's the expert here and the
fact that extremely ill people have
different views about what it means for
their lives to go well or for what it
means for their lives to meet a minimum
threshold of tolerability is a reason to
respect that diversity rather than to
force those who prefer an assisted death
to instead have to endure the suffering
they are desperate to avoid
it's true i think that a request for
assisted dying should prompt us to
investigate other ways in which a
person's distress can be alleviated
before proceeding to assist them in
dying but that is an argument for a
robust filter on access to assisted
dying not only a palliative care filter
which is what happens in belgium where a
request will excuse me a request for
euthanasia prompts extensive
investigation of what other sorts of
palliative care might be able to address
the patient's concerns but also what you
could call a social support filter so if
someone asks their doctor for help in
dying of course it's right to see what
else could be done to relieve their
distress
they may be suffering from treatable
depression their pain control may be
inadequate or they may be isolated and
need more social support
my argument is that it's acceptable for
a sister dying to be the last option on
that palliative and social support menu
when we can't do any more to relieve
someone's distress
we shouldn't abandon them to a dying
process which they find unbearable
now the distinguished philosopher james
rachel's asked us to imagine a choice
between two deaths
if we opt for the first death we die
quietly and painlessly at the age of 80
after being given a lethal injection the
second death involves us dying a few
days later
at the age of 80 plus a few days
but from an affliction which is so
distressing and frightening that we
spend those last few days howling like a
dog with our family standing helplessly
by
now i'm prepared to believe that some
people's religious faith would lead them
to prefer the second option that's
obviously absolutely fine but surely the
vast majority of us basing our decision
upon our own preferences would opt for
the first death
and if the first death is so obviously
preferable
surely there's something wrong with
legal system which absolutely forbids
the painless death
and insists upon allowing only the
terrifying one now of course palliative
care and the hospice movements have made
the process of dying less
institutionalized and more comfortable
for millions of people
every patient should obviously have the
right to high quality palliative and
hospice care
but while many people's pain and
distress can be effectively managed and
alleviated the core really of my
argument is the claim that this is not
universally the case
now of course this is an empirical claim
but in my view the evidence to support
it is overwhelming we know that the
desire for assisted dying exists upon
among people who have access to really
good quality palliative care in oregon
92 percent of those who ask for assisted
suicide are enrolled in hospice care
diane pretty and now debbie persi in the
uk have felt so strongly about this
issue that they've devoted years of
their lives to fighting protracted
battles in the courts
if it's true that palliative care cannot
alleviate everyone's suffering those who
argue against legalization of assisted
dying are forcing people like diane
priti and debbie purdy to experience
deaths they don't want because other
people's values are more important than
their own perception of their own
suffering
i'm fairly sure that there will come a
time in my own life when i don't want to
suffer anymore and would prefer an
assisted death but i'm not allowed to
have one
and that strikes me as a gross
interference with my right to make the
most important decisions about my life
for myself
if i want an assisted death i would be
saying that my life has ceased to have
value to me that's an entirely different
thing from saying that i no longer have
any value as a human being
many opponents of legalization
argue that to permit assisted death
would be to devalue the sick the elderly
and the dying but i think that's
illogical
i really respect debbie purdy's view
that there may come a time when she's
had enough and wants to be helped to die
but i don't think that means when that
time comes she will cease to be an
extremely valuable human being
opponents of assisted dying have the
right to say this is not for me i want
to live until the bitter end and if i'm
a doctor i want no part in helping
patients to die they do not have the
right to impose that preference on me
emily jackson thank you very much indeed
our first speaker against the motion is
alex carlisle qc he's a practicing
barrister he was a lib dem mp for 14
years and now sits in the house of lords
along the way he was the first mp to
campaign for the rights of transsexuals
earlier this year he became the joint
chair of living and dying well a public
policy think tank set up to look into
the arguments surrounding exactly this
debate alex
[Applause]
can you all hear me upstairs as well at
the back
microphone system working good
well first of all can i say how grateful
i am to intelligence squared into the
evening standard for giving us the
opportunity of a debate in front of such
a large and interested audience tonight
i come to this debate as a secular
person as a parliamentarian as a lawyer
and particularly as a person who's taken
part in the process of making laws in
both houses of parliament
i recognize that this is a subject that
provokes great emotion
but it's one of those subjects on which
we have to recognize that serious people
with the greatest of courtesy can
disagree seriously about what is such a
serious subject
i don't claim to monopoly of rectitude
we can never be certain of our rectitude
on a subject like this we can only
believe in it and there are people who
believe in their rectitude strongly on
both sides
but i would say to you at the outset
that we should not look upon the phrase
assisting suicide as a euphemism because
it can be seen as a euphemism there is a
danger of that
if somebody assists suicide the reality
is that that person is helping to kill
another human being
and in law it's a form of homicide
and what we're doing here is talking
about legalizing a form of homicide
now my starting point i hope is an
entirely ethical one
that it is wrong to take or assist in
taking another person's life
unless it is permitted by law
now you know we can often ask for laws
that would make our lives different
because we would like that law to be
made
but that's not the standard law has to
be judged by an objective standard it
has to be good law it has to be certain
law that is to say law that can be
applied with certainty and can be
clearly understood
and my starting point is the law is
clear at the moment it is well
understood the director of public
prosecution's guidelines as a result of
debbie purdy's case are particularly
clear
and in my judgment they provide the
right dynamic tension that enables one
to judge cases where there has been
assistance of suicide
and the director of public prosecutions
with the sensitivity which he's come to
be recognized for judges these cases
carefully
now the starting point in law actually
is this heavily tatty volume that i've
been carrying with me for about the last
30 years i used to cite it to judges at
one time and they used to look at me as
though i was talking a foreign language
it's the european convention on human
rights but these days it's something
that's cited daily to judges in almost
every part of the law
and article 2 makes it absolutely clear
and this is a unqualified right
that nobody should be deprived of his
life intentionally saving very clear
circumstances
and the clear circumstances are set out
as uh in defending oneself i am
summarizing now defending oneself or
other people in face of really serious
danger
or in a war defined as such
under the law of war i don't know how
many people have read article 2 in this
room but it repays reading for there are
no exceptions
and indeed debbie purdy's case created
no exceptions she won her case and it
was reflected faithfully in the
guidelines made by the dpp
so i would argue that what we have is a
law that is true to the european
convention
that protects weak and vulnerable people
that protects those who may have changed
their mind about this issue
without the danger of dying without it
being clear that they've changed their
mind
and it protects those who are
feeling that they're a burden on their
family and a burden on the resources of
their families
nobody has produced a certain way or
even a a a an intelligently thought out
way of judging
what has been called autonomy
and indeed i shudder slightly if i may
say so with great respect to professor
jack jackson's excellent speech
at the way in which that word autonomy
is used sometimes by lawyers as though
it was an absolute right
autonomy is not an absolute right the
law does allow a great deal of autonomy
but the law also takes away a great deal
of autonomy at the most crude level the
right to travel free upon the railways
is taken away by the law that forces you
to pay for your ticket
and it's a matter of judgment where one
allows autonomy to run and where one
limits autonomy in the public interest
and the interest of good law
further
useful and interesting though debates
like this are
i'm afraid the reality that those in
favor of this proposed change have to
face
is that there is only one place where
this law can be changed and that's in
parliament
and so far
parliament insofar as it has been asked
to judge this law has rejected it
comprehensively
i'm puzzled by the approach that's been
taken because nobody in the house of
commons has taken up this issue for as a
private bill near the top of the agenda
so it could be fully debated and taken
through all its processes in the house
of commons
the joffrey bill
was defeated to the extent that the
house of lords didn't want to hear any
more of it by nearly 150 votes to 100
and the falconer amendment was defeated
in the house of lords by 194
to 141 and let me tell you the reasons
why i think in huge debates and very
interesting debates those proposals were
rejected
first of all it is assumed that doctors
would be the judges
now there are two points about that
the first is that a lot of doctors don't
want to be the judges of whether a
person should have assisted suicide
and therefore you have a self-selecting
group of doctors some of whom of course
most of whom are extremely honorable
people
but they select themselves because they
are the ones who believe in the process
secondly one has to be realistic and say
that doctors are no more guaranteed to
be capital g good than any other group
of people in society they're no more
good as a group than lawyers or plumbers
or
refuse collectors they are a group of
people with particular skills
and i do not know where this myth of the
reliability of a self-selecting group of
doctors comes from it certainly hasn't
been proved to be reliable
the reality is
that first of all a law permitting
assisted suicide won't happen because
it's contrary to article 2 of the
european convention on human rights
whatever the dutch and the belgians are
doing apparently people in those
countries have not fully challenged what
is permitted there but it would be
challenged here
secondly it's completely contrary to our
legal tradition and concepts we simply
do not accept that one member of the
public should be involved in killing
another member of the public
safe in the circumstances i've set out
thirdly nobody has produced anything
remotely acceptable as a way of
achieving this
lord faulkner
proposed his amendment for assisted
suicide he was a former lord chancellor
he had a panoply of legal experts as his
disposal he proposed that certificates
should be obtained from coroners
when i read his amendment i telephoned
the coroners they hadn't been asked and
they were absolutely furious that this
had been proposed without their consent
and it's simply an example of
floundering around to try and find a way
of producing a system that would be
reliable
um who are these selfs this
self-selecting cadre of death regulators
to quote christina odoney but she's
right in using that phrase who would
carry out this work
further and i look forward to hearing
from baroness warnock she said on in
september 2008
pensioners in mental decline are wasting
people's lives because of the care they
require and should be allowed to opt for
euthanasia even if they are not in pain
well the premise behind that is deeply
shocking that pensioners in mental
decline are wasting other people's lives
anybody who's had a loved one and i had
a beloved godmother who had a very
serious mental decline knew that she
wasn't herself but she was enjoying
every memory she was able to sum up even
in the random way in which they appeared
at the end of her speech professor
jackson said this should be the last
option on the menu
i'm afraid i find that very unattractive
language particularly coming from so
distinguished a lawyer
the the the metaphor of a menu is not a
good one here we're talking about law
not menus
and in my judgment and i would urge this
upon you there is no
system of law which anyone has been able
to devise
which would ensure that the vulnerable
the sick the disabled
and those who change their mind would be
protected let's leave things just as
they are
[Applause]
lord carlyle thank you very much indeed
um our second speaker to the motion is
debbie purdy debbie was diagnosed with
ms in 1995 when she was 31 she wants to
choose when she wants to die preferably
with the help of her husband her
campaign prompted the dpp to publish new
guidelines clarifying the circumstances
in which an individual might not face
prosecution for helping a loved one to
die and her campaign uh for
dying to be made legal in the uk as per
our motion continues debbie purdy
[Applause]
thank you i'm not going to get to the
lectern because you wouldn't be able to
see me and i'm far too attractive to be
kept behind a lectern
honestly
um
i'm not really sure where to start
because the thing is i don't believe
doctors have got a right to make a
decision about the quality of my life
and i don't believe anybody else has got
the right to decide the value of my life
and whether it should come to an end i
believe i have that decision
i think it's
frightening people to say that doctors
will make these decisions we very
clearly do not want doctors to make
decisions
about whether somebody's life
is
unbearable
whether it's unreasonable for them to
continue living that decision is down to
the person living it
and at the moment the law
is a mess
the law states that to aid a bet counsel
or procure the suicide of another
is illegal and punishable by 14 years in
jail
so far the people who have been assisted
to go to switzerland for instance to
make use of their laws
nobody has been prosecuted that doesn't
mean that to say that nobody will be
but nobody has yet
in terms of assisting somebody to die
that there have been a number of cases
where people have been prosecuted for
assisting or for not helping to keep
somebody alive and a number of cases
where people have not been prosecuted
what we need is clarity as citizens of
this country we are entitled to know
what our laws mean and how they will be
used by
the instruments of that law whether
that's the police or the crown
prosecution service
or whoever and the fact that politicians
have so far lacked the courage to
discuss the issue
is not a reason to say it shouldn't be
discussed
you
the law that we currently are governed
by
was introduced in 1961 and i think it is
a progressive
good intelligent law for 1961 the one
that made suicide it ceased to be
illegal but still said that assisting a
suicide was
but that law
was framed in 1961
that's before i was born before my
husband was born and i would take a
guess looking around i can't see many
people but before a lot of you were born
as well
and that although i think it's important
that the law be looked at seriously and
i think passing a law quickly or on the
basis of
you know a short discussion or one or
two cases would be a mistake
i think it's the fact that politicians
have not yet discussed it is not to say
that the current law is an appropriate
law and one that you and i wish to be
governed by
that
every since 1961
what's changed
homosexuality has been legalized not
made compulsory i hasten to add
abortion has been legalized but not made
compulsory we've had the war in vietnam
nelson mandela was arrested charged and
spent 27 years in jail
before being freed to become the first
black president of south africa
1961 is a long time ago and i think our
law our politicians have got a duty to
us our citizens to look at the laws and
make sure that they represent
our best interests
in this century
and not to say that whatever we've got
is probably okay because it's out of
date
that
this year
um the general medical council have said
that some research that was done by
clive sealy i'm really sorry by the way
i can't read
um my eyesight's horrible
um by
clive seely
um was that of
those deaths that were presided over by
physicians
not .2
were assisted to die after their ex
after the patient's express request
not 0.3 percent were assisted to die
not with their express request that
means two and a half thousand deaths
every year
fall outside of the current law
i'm not saying that therefore and that's
just doctors i'm not saying that those
people should be prosecuted i'm saying
that that means we should look again at
the law to develop a law which is
appropriate for this citizenship
in this decade of this century
and that we should stop being
curtailed by the fact that
50 years ago
the politicians had enough courage to
look at a law and say we've got to
update this
when this law was passed
if you were told you had cancer you
pretty much had a death sentence
now that's not true the majority of
people who are told they have cancer
have access to amazing palliative care
amazing care by doctors who can help
them
live longer and live productive lives
and after i think it's five years or six
years of being free of cancer be told
they are cured
that i'm not saying that we should
ignore that or go back on that what i'm
saying is that as
members of this society
we have a right to be taken seriously
that our views on our own lives should
be considered as
important and the fact that our
politicians who represent us
are too cowardly
to take up the issue and discuss it
is not
an indication that they're right but
rather an indication that we have to
fight harder and that we have a right to
be represented by people who represent
our interests
if it is to say
that it is okay to kill somebody in war
but not okay to assist somebody to die
who wants to be assisted who is
suffering unbearably
in excruciating pain or finding their
lives unbearable for whatever reason
it's a strange world that we are saying
to kill somebody because they happen to
live in the wrong country is okay
but to assist somebody to ease their
suffering
is not
we have to be prepared to look at the
legal situation we find ourselves in
and that
whilst i think palliative care has
improved enormously i think it still has
a long way to go and i'm prepared to
fight with my
last breath
that palliative care should be available
across the board irrespective of what
disease you happen to have
to make sure that people
have the best care that is available
in this society
but
saying that does not mean that i believe
palliative care is always good enough or
always provides some provide a solution
where people would find
living
an acceptable situation that some people
that if some people
find that certain situations
are beyond their tolerance
it is possible that we could have
the same symptom
and emily finds it completely bearable
and completely acceptable and that i
find it unbearable
and unacceptable and it should be our
choice not doctors not family members
not
um
a doctor
not a politician not member of
parliament but ourselves who make that
decision
and if we look
if we look at what's happening at the
moment
of people traveling to switzerland
people making botched attempts at
suicide and ending up in a worse
situation than they were before
doctors making decisions about the
possible end of somebody's life
what it means is
this is happening at the moment and in
order for this to be
properly brought under control in a way
that we as a society find acceptable
we have to be prepared to make a law
that is acceptable in the united kingdom
in the 21st century
not count on belgium or switzerland or
holland or oregon or anywhere else but
what is acceptable to us
uh
our second speaker against the motion is
patrick stone paddy to his friends he's
macmillan reader in palliative medicine
at st george's university of london he
was awarded his md in cancer-related
fatigue and his special interests
include prognostication in advanced
cancer and quality of life assessment
paddy stone
thank you very much good evening
let me start by explaining that i am a
specialist in palliative medicine
i am a hospice doctor
every year i look after approximately a
thousand patients who are dying
from advanced diseases such as cancer
motor neurone disease or dementia
if the opinion polls are to be believed
the majority of the people in this
country and presumably the majority of
people in this auditorium are in favor
of assisted suicide for the terminally
ill
and yet those same opinion polls
repeatedly show that the overwhelming
majority of palliative care doctors like
myself
are opposed
and what i want to do this evening is
trying to explain to you some of the
reasons why that might be the case
i think the first thing to state is
although i look after many many patients
who are dying
very few of them actually request
assistance with dying
and those requests that i do receive as
professor
emily jackson alluded to
are often motivated by fear
fear of what the future might hold and
the commonest fear that i encounter is
that patients will be subjected to a
burdensome medical intervention at the
end of their lives
that they will be put on drips that they
will be ventilated that they will be
tube fed
these are the things that people are
frightened of
so the first thing that i say to
patients is that there is no need for
them to seek an assisted death
there is no need for them to campaign to
change the law
they are quite within their rights to
refuse any life-prolonging treatment
that they choose to do so if they are
terminally ill or indeed at any stage of
their life
but since the 2005 mental capacity act
they can go further than that they can
write legally binding advanced refusals
of treatment
they can even appoint lasting powers of
attorney to trusted relatives or friends
to make these decisions on their behalf
there is no need for anybody in this
country to be exposed to meddlesome
medical intervention at the end of their
lives
the second most common fear that i
encounter
is a fear of pain or a traumatic death
as has been alluded
to think as a palliative care doctor i
find this particularly hard because i've
looked after thousands of patients
and by the overwhelming majority of
patients with good palliative care can
achieve a dignified peaceful and
painless death
and i think a good example of how
misinformation about what can happen at
the end of life
can influence decision making
is provided by the example of patients
with motor neurone disease
in the netherlands
in that country one in five patients
without condition
currently seek an assisted death
euthanasia or assisted suicide and the
commonest reason that they give
is a fear of choking to death
that is
not
what happens to patients with motor
neurone disease the overwhelming
evidence
from studies looking at how patients die
with most neurone disease is that they
can die a peaceful and a painless death
less than half of one percent
of all reported deaths in motor neurone
disease
have any element of choking
and experience in hospices and
palliative care has shown that even in
those extreme circumstances judicious
use of morphine and sedation can relieve
any distress
but we're left with a situation where 20
percent of people
without condition in the netherlands are
availing themselves of an assisted death
because of fear about what the future
might hold
i think as a palliative care doctor i'm
also entirely skeptical of the idea that
by restricting assisted dying to the
terminally ill we will somehow make it
safer or less controversial
in my clinical practice the terminal
phase of an illness relates specifically
to the last few hours
or days of life
and i know
that for for everybody at that stage of
their illness we can make them
comfortable
because even in the most extreme and
dire circumstances we could render
patients unconscious if that were
necessary
and keep them comfortable until they
died from their underlying disease
there is no need for patients
to suffer at the very end of life
what would be gained by legalizing
assisted suicide for those patients
would be a small amount of extra
autonomy to choose the hour or the day
on which they died but is that
sufficient justification for exposing
large numbers of vulnerable patients to
increased risk
but perhaps
but perhaps i shall we have questions
later sir
but perhaps the
uh proponents of assisted dying are not
suggesting that we restrict it to people
in the last few hours or days of life
perhaps they're suggesting that we
should allow it for people in the last
few weeks months or years of life
and indeed uh in the netherlands there
is a campaign currently to allow
euthanasia and assisted dying for the
old
the lonely those who are tired of life
once you move away from a
close
definition of the terminal phase as
being the last few hours or days
it becomes an entirely fluid concept
altogether
after all life itself could be
considered to be a terminal illness
moreover doctors themselves are very
poor at prognosticating
in a recent study
doctors were asked to categorise whether
patients with advanced cancer would live
for weeks months or years
and they only got their categorization
right in just over 50 percent of cases
that's slightly better than the toss of
a coin
i'm also highly skeptical of the idea
that assisted suicide can be considered
to be something hermetically sealed and
distinct from euthanasia
imagine the proponents of assisted
suicide have their way and i've
prescribed a drug a lethal cocktail to
one of my patients who's taken half of
the medication and slipped into a coma
and is now suspended in front of me
somewhere between life and death and
perhaps in some pain or discomfort
surely these same proponents would now
argue that it would only be ethical it
would only be proper it would only be
humane to allow me to finish off the job
would it not
assisted suicide evolving inevitably
into euthanasia and if you think that's
a contrived or unrealistic example in
the netherlands one in five cases of
assisted suicide ends with the
prescription of a lethal injection by
the doctor
the clear distinction between assisted
suicide and euthanasia
is wholly
illusory
finally i think i'm frightened and
concerned that if we legalized assisted
suicide it would have significant
adverse effects on the whole culture and
practice of medicine and the trust that
we rely on with our vulnerable patients
if it was a
legal for to
assist people in their suicide we would
have to treat that as just one other
option for patients at the end of life
we would be obliged to discuss
for instance mr jones we've diagnosed
your advanced cancer we can offer you
chemotherapy
we could offer you good palliative care
but i'm obliged to remind you that you
could also avail yourself of an assisted
suicide in a culture like this
how long do you think it would be
before the rights of a minority to
choose the hour and the day on which
they die
is transformed into a duty or at least
at the very least an expectation or an
obligation on the vulnerable majority to
accept an assisted death
thank you for listening and i look
forward to your questions
paddy stone thank you very much our last
speaker in favor of the motion that
assisted suicide should be legalized is
mary warnock the moral philosopher she's
a former headmistress of oxford high
school and mistress of guertin college
cambridge she's long been an outspoken
proponent of voluntary euthanasia and
she said she believes it is genuinely
wicked of doctors to disregard the
wishes of someone who explicitly wishes
to die founder warnock
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
it's very difficult to come after all
the other speakers because one keeps on
thinking of things i want to change
about what i was going to say myself and
some of the things
i have changed but
one thing i haven't changed i wanted to
divide
what i was going to say into two parts
one of them
concerned with the law and one of them
yes i'm rather short
i'd rather be concerned with more
perhaps fundamental questions i feel
very hesitant in talking about the law
at all in the presence of the formidable
lawyer we've just heard but
i will have to mention the law and one
of the things i feel most grateful to
libby purdy for
is that her
limited limited success
we've got the director of public
prosecutions to set out his guidelines
earlier this year
has shown
that the law is
rarely
in a tangle
in this country and i think
one thing is certain and that is what
everyone's views are the law has to be
changed sooner or later because at the
moment
we have the situation where in this
country
if somebody
assists somebody else to die
at whatever stage of their illness and i
don't terribly like confining us to
terminal illness because i asked debbie
and she told me that she does not regard
herself as terminally ill but she is
incurably ill
so we're not necessarily talking about
the last two or three days of life
we're talking also by people who know
that their
illness will not be
cured
but in this country
the law
lays down
that
assisted suicide
is a criminal offense and moreover
the present law
has made things worse
because it's confused
the case of somebody who
helps somebody to commit suicide or who
like kills them out of compassion and
pity
and not being able to bear their
suffering with those people who on the
internet
incite
young people to commit suicide together
or in
droves or with a partner now that seems
to me
genuinely a terrible offense
but it's nothing whatever to do
with the people who
probably reluctantly
help somebody to do what they want to do
which is in their life
but the present law has merged those two
things together and i think that is a
disaster has got to be undone
but the second thing about the law is
that it seems to be saying
there is
a
consistent suicide in this country is a
criminal offence but if you go abroad
it's okay
now that is an incredibly legalistic
view
it's okay in switzerland because the law
says it's okay in certain circumstances
it's not okay here because the law says
that it's not
but surely behind
the law
that would criminalize assisted suicide
is a moral judgment about whether it is
in certain circumstances right
or whether it's never right
to help somebody to do what they want to
do
which is die
when they've had enough
and therefore i think it trivializes the
issue to say it's all right if you go to
switzerland but not all right here it's
a kind of absurd
extension of the concept of not in my
backyard perfectly all right if you go
to switzerland
now i think that is
a condition of the law with which we
can't ultimately live we've got to sort
things out and of course the other thing
that's wrong with the law is that the
director of public prosecution's
guidelines
were directed towards people like
debbie's husband
who
will in the end when she wants it help
her to die
and is laying out
the circumstances in which he will
escape prosecution
but this has nothing to do and nothing
to say
about doctors and professional medical
people
who may
feel themselves that it will be morally
right
to
hasten the death of somebody who
desperately wants to die
because of their
pain discomfort humiliation
shame
thoroughly
feeling fed up with the life they're
living
and so i now want to talk about those
medical people who find themselves
in this position
it seems to me that
i'm not talking
at all
about
autonomy
or anybody's right to die
or right to determine when they die i
don't believe that people have
that right
i don't i that is
a huge number of cases where patient
autonomy
is restricted
and
rightly restricted you can't choose what
treatment you're going to have however
expensive it is
you can't choose what doctor you're
going to have to look after unless
you're rich enough
to pay for a particular doctor you have
to take what comes
if you live in a particular part of the
country you can't choose to have
one kind of drug
for your
high blood pressure because in that part
of the country will find that it's been
deemed too expensive or given another
you have all kinds of restrictions on
your choice as a patient so i'm not
relying on the argument for autonomy
but what i am relying on is
the fact
that although the people
of whom we've just heard
a good and professional exponent
say
that palliative care is the solution
and that nobody in need die
a horrible death
that actually does not conform
to experience
it may be that most cancer patients
have access to palliative care either in
a hospice
or at home
but not everybody dies of cancer
and there are many many kinds of
horrible deaths some of them connected
with old age as well as disease
some of them connected with all kinds of
lung conditions not necessarily cancer
that
inhibit breathing
lots of them connected with an inability
to swallow
and i admit that a lot of the horror
of this kind of death is fear
and sometimes fear can be allayed
sometimes it can't
but palliative care
i'm sure is wonderful when it works but
it doesn't always work
and there are people who
are
rarely longing to die
and i don't see any moral justification
whatsoever
for
the moral opinions of one lot of people
namely the doctors and perhaps the
lawyers
to override their own moral opinion
which is that they have had enough and
it will be right and good
that they should be
allowed to die in peace
now i
think that
what i'm asking for
is
ultimately a change of the law
that makes
assisted suicide in this kind of case as
well as in the case of debbie here
legal in some
situations
but i'm asking first
for
a change in the attitude
of the medical profession
and actually i think there is evidence
that this is gradually coming about
because i do believe
that
medical people for whom on the whole i
have the largest enormous
admiration
partly because of being dependent on
them as we all are but i do have a great
admiration for them
but i think that they
do believe
that their mission
and i use the word advisedly that their
mission
is to
help people to make things better for
people
to
make their lives
better rather than worse
and i believe that what we need
is a change of attitude in the medical
profession which may
come to think that living longer
is not always in the best interest of
the patient life
is sometimes
less desirable than death
we are all going to die
and doctors know that as well as anybody
else or better but yet they're
incredibly reluctant to talk about the
fact
that somebody is dying they don't use
the word dying
they
treat people as if they were all the
same or waiting to be cured or made
better or if they can't be killed or
made better than palliative care is what
they draw out of the hat
but supposing that palliative care
doesn't work
supposing that the person is let's say
very old
knows that they
maybe have been cured
from some disease
by drugs and whatnot but yet knows that
they're not really better they're going
to die
and die soon
could it not become part of the doctor's
repertoire
to think
that
how to help that patient
how to make things better for
that patient
would be to help her to die
to make things easier
to
bring death on
rather than constantly hold it at bay
would this not
perhaps be
the
conclusion
of compassion
and so what
i'm referring to is not anything to do
with rights or autonomy
it's not even anything to do with the
law
because the argument
of
people
who lawyers and others who are against
this is often that the law would be
abused
the
horrible predatory relatives would come
sweeping in and say go on get rid of her
she's
she's using up our money she's using up
our time so and so forth well of course
there may be horrible predatory
relatives
any law
can be abused you could refuse
to give
anyone in child birth pathogen on the
ground somebody could give them too much
pathogen and they'd die
or they might become addicted to
president and go on taking president for
the rest of our lives
any law can be abused but that cannot be
a reason for not thinking of the moral
arguments that lie behind
the law and indeed lie behind any law
and the law here
is compassionate thank you very much
and our final speaker
against changing the law is richard
harris bishop of oxford for 19 years
familiar to us all from radio 4's
thought for the day he's gresham
professor of divinity at king's college
london a man with a passion for social
justice he's currently writing a book
entitled issues of life and death
richard harris
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening everybody like everybody
else
i very much
feel for people
who are in the grip of irremediable and
irreversible
suffering and i really genuinely don't
know how i would feel or how i would
react if i was in that situation myself
suffering from a debilitating illness
emily earlier on said
i would uh not want to continue living i
can sympathize with that but if i was in
that position i just simply don't know
how i would react
and the reason i mentioned this right at
the beginning is to make it clear that i
don't approach this debate with any
claim uh to be uh on the high moral
ground or to be some kind of moral hero
like every other human being i'm frail
and
fearful
and because others have considered the
issue from medical and legal standpoints
i'm going to raise some wider
considerations if i may about what it
really means to be a human being in
society
however once again i must make it clear
that i'm not depending on any moral law
against what hamlet called
self-slaughter
nor
on any idea that it is god and god alone
who decides the moment of our death
those may or may not be good arguments
but i want to make it quite clear those
are not the arguments that i am
deploying now
what i want to do is to question
some all-pervading assumptions in our
society as a whole and particularly in
this debate about what it really means
to be human
and i think that the research on what
has happened in oregon is very revealing
because it shows that people who take up
the option of assisted dying are those
who like to be in control of their lives
those in the age range 18 to 64 are
three times more likely to avail
themselves of oregon's death with
dignity act than the over 85 group in
short it is those who have recently led
busy professional lives those who
recently been in
active in control who want to choose the
moment of their death and it is not the
most elderly
now i'd like to suggest that this
picture is in fact a very revealing one
and it fits in with what emily said
earlier on that there is a particular
subset of people who want more control
over their lives
but i think that it reveals three
assumptions first of all a very
individualistic assumption of what it is
to be a human being in society it is as
it were the lonely individual deciding
for him or herself
and it is this view of course which has
dominated european culture since the
17th century which is focused
particularly uh in somebody like
kierkegaard
the fact is however we're not isolated
individuals and i think the africans
have a much richer and deeper
understanding when they talk about
ubuntu we are persons only in and
through our relationship with other
persons
now the second assumption which is
revealed by the oregon picture which i
think uh reveals something about our
society
and that is the assumption that it is
the ability to control our lives that
defines us as human beings
now again i'd like it to make it quite
clear i like to be in control of my
lives as much as anybody in this room
perhaps even more so i hate the thought
of not being in control
of my life
but i have to face the fact at the
beginning of my life i was totally
dependent on others at the very end of
my life i'm inevitably bound to be
totally dependent on our other others
the fact that it matter is that we are
interdependent
and that
the relationship between being dependent
and being interdependent are intertwined
and very greatly during the course of
our lives and it's quite wrong to simply
define us as human beings in terms of
our ability to control and manipulate
our lives and the third false assumption
which i think is revealed with the
origin picture
is that if we actually lose control of
our lives and become more dependent on
others somehow we lose our value and
dignity as human beings now of course we
don't every human being in whatever
state is a value to be respected and
cherished as such
so i won't begin therefore by by asking
you if you were to to question uh the
widespread assumption in our society
which had really been going since the
17th century that it is us as lonely
individuals in control of our lives who
rarely define what it is to be us
nevertheless even if you can see that
you might very rightly say about there
are people who really want to die this
is their considered choice and they're
asking for our help to do so
and of course we've heard very very
powerful pleas this evening along those
lines but here again if i may i'd like
to suggest three points which should
make us hesitate very greatly
first of all
of course it's not always morally right
to do what other people ask you to do
i imagine that everybody in this room if
they were faced with a teenager who asks
you to help them to die would refuse
of course we would refuse we would seek
to to help them in some other ways we
would look around for some other way of
alleviating their distress and we would
regard it as profoundly wrong to help a
teenager to kill themselves
but then all right suppose someone in a
desperate sleep burns out bursts out
blurts out as they have done well you
wouldn't treat a dog like this you have
your dog put down to end their suffering
why won't you do the same for me
a very heartfelt plea and i i don't in
any way question the real pain
behind it
but the point is quite simply we're not
dogs
we're human beings when a dog is in
great pain at the end of their life the
kindest thing you can do is indeed
simply to end their pain by putting them
down
now in relation to human beings of
course we ought to do all we can to
relieve a person's pain and paddy has
told us all that can be uh done now
and thank god through the great advances
in palliative care in almost every case
it is possible for a person to die
peacefully but the point is that
relieving pain
is not the only thing which we owe to
other human beings in their distress
we want to assure them that they're
still of value and that they're still
wanted
now there is an extreme situation which
is sometimes put forward in this debates
a petrol tank has gone up in flames the
driver's caught in his cabin is going to
roast to an excruciating death there's
no way you can get him out and he begs
you to shoot him
now i think that in that situation it is
entirely morally right to accede to his
reset request and to shoot him because
his death from burning is certain
immediate and horrific
but the people who seek assistance in
dying are not in that position they're
still very much with us
and we what we can offer them is not
just as much alleviation of their pain
and distress as possible but the
assurance that we're still with them
that we will accompany them on their
journey and that in this journey they
their continuing presence with us is
still of value
now the great american ethicist paul
ramsey in his discussion of ending the
lives of people
diagnosed with permanent vegetative
state and other similar conditions
suggested it would be right let us say
to inject a person in that state with a
lethal drug if quotes they are
irretrievably inaccessible to human care
but in other circumstances he said we
should not quote hasten them from the
here and now in which they still claim a
faithful presence from us
i find that a very powerful phrase we
shouldn't hasten them from the here and
now in which they still claim a faithful
presence for us
for if we hasten them from the here and
now away from us and their continuing
presence with us what in is it in fact
that we are saying to them this is not
an argument from selfishness as though
it is we who cannot bear to let them go
it is about assuring that they still
have a place that we want to accompany
them on their journey and that they
still of value and the great advantage
of having a law which uh does not allow
for a sister dying it is that it assures
people in whatever state that they're
there that it's not just an individual
but it is a whole society as a whole
which their values their their their
their presence with us so what i'm
asking us to do is to question various
assumptions which i think permeate this
debate and perhaps which are pretty
widespread in our society as a whole
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much lord harry's um now
before i open it up to the audience let
me just give you the result of the
entrance poll for the motion that
assisted suicide should be legalized
against 110
don't knows 117
so there's quite a lot of work to be
done by the all males on my left um
question time then keep it brief if you
would because i'm sure lots of people
want to get in don't make speeches make
a point or ask a question preferably
both as quickly as you can i'll go to a
hand i can see up over there and can i
have another one here coming up
afterwards and i'm coming to you okay
thank you
um my question is i don't know how many
other people in the room have had to
make choice but i did and i could
even though i love my husband very much
and i think it's because
it shouldn't be up to the family so i
think
could there be a law that when that
situation does arrive it isn't in the
hands of the family i don't know how
many other people
have ever had to make that choice for a
loved one but it is incredibly hard
okay i'm just going to take this another
question here another point here trying
to gather you together in bunches so we
can get us here as many as we can yes
sir take the microphone if you would
thank you i last like to ask bishop
harris
he mentioned that uh
a driver in a train was about to be
burned to death
he would be permitted to shoot him
what would the law have to say about
that
well well if you if you don't mind i'm
not going to get us diverted onto that
because i think it is actually slightly
off the point there was another there
was another question here that's it
well he can answer it in a minute if you
really feel he should but i i think it's
uh lord carlisle in his very interesting
speech told us a great deal about what
the law is but that is really irrelevant
to this debate which is about what the
law ought to be and
[Applause]
and i think debbie purdy put his example
of somebody in insufferable pain which
can't be ended does sometimes happen and
plainly that person should be allowed to
be killed not merely starved to death
but
i think the speakers for the motion have
failed to do something very important
which is to say what the law ought to be
and that has not been defined yet and i
hope perhaps in that classic speeches it
will be
right well let me bring in alex carlisle
on that and perhaps you can scoop up the
burning lorry driver at the same time
is this microphone working yeah i can
scoop up the first question by saying i
did say what the law ought to be i said
it should remain as it is
and i would to scoop up a brief previous
question i would leave the law exactly
as it is
um in dealing with the uh driver in the
burning cab
it's not that the law should be changed
for the driver in the burning cab of
course the driver would not be
prosecuted we have a benign prosecution
process in this country in which a
judgment is made by a dual code test
which has been recognized time and time
again by the courts as having some
importance
and i think it's absolutely good enough
for the director of public prosecutions
to decide not only whether there is
evidence but whether it's in the public
interest for the person to be prosecuted
and plainly the director would decide it
was not in the public interest now i
didn't quite hear the first question
well i'm going to ask debbie to answer
that okay
debbie the first point was that it
shouldn't be up to the family
i agree it shouldn't be up to the family
it should be up to the patient
and i think that what we need to have is
as terry pratchett talked about
tribunals when people are still alive to
be able to discuss
why they want to die to give families
the opportunity if somebody thinks
they're a burden so that families have
the opportunity of saying auntie may
you're not a burden we love having you
here so that
doctors have got the opportunity of
saying that they have a different way of
treating people but if any of those
solutions are not sufficient for the
patient the patient should have the
right to decide they want to end their
lives and if they can't do that
themselves which is often the case they
should be able to ask for assistance
but how can they ask for assistance if
they can't do it themselves i mean
that's the point isn't it you come down
to that fine moment when perhaps you
haven't spoken early enough and you're
beyond being able to speak
you have to rely then on your loved one
to know what you would want is that what
you're saying no i don't
i personally and this is why i think
it's very hard to say exactly what the
law should be i think it should be part
of a discussion
because my personal belief is that if
somebody hasn't specifically said
oh
i want to die
now
i don't think anybody else has got the
right to make the choices for them i
think it has always got to be the
patient who makes the choice
i go to a question there and then i'll
come to the one on the front row here
thank you hello
um i was fortunate enough to live very
near jackie kennedy onassis much smaller
apartment unfortunately but anyway she
did die uh her own
um wish in her own way which her son
announced the next day she was famous
enough and rich enough to have that
choice an average engineer schoolteacher
no way
secondly you may all know my terrible
accent i'm sorry for that sort of an
ex-american the most common cause of
bankruptcy in the u.s what is it
health care
your loved ones will sell their diamonds
their homes whatever
i get nervous so i have my notes here
in your will you probably don't know
this better than i do though i have
members of my family who were surgeons
and lawyers and i respect very much when
one of you said they're just humans like
the rest of us there's the good bad in
the medium like any profession
in your will
should you say which family member
decides because if you leave it among
three or four family members then what
they'll be in disarray won't they i'm
i'm that's enough thank you very much
should you say in your will in in any
kind of will that you might leave um
jackie i'm sorry at the end
should you say which family member
should
take the decision for you well currently
um the way things work is that you can
make and this is this is we're talking
about refusal of treatment here we're
not talking about
a sister dying you can nominate somebody
to make decisions for you when you let
lose capacity or you can make a living
will with your directions what you want
to happen in so you are currently able
to nominate somebody to take decisions
once you've lost capacity but that
doesn't fly at all to assisted dying
which is absolutely illegal okay let's
have a point from the front here
a couple of points um to debbie purdy
this is a case of one disabled person to
another by the way
um two points first one
um you say you want to have autonomy
about when you die well with respect
you're not going to have it because
somebody's unless you're planning that
automatically anybody who says they want
to die there's no
judge or panel to discuss it which would
be a complete nightmare and i hope you'd
agree about that then one way or another
somebody's going to be deciding for you
the second point which i'd like to make
slightly ironically not a digger
intelligence squared
which is to ask how many severely
disabled people there are in this room
so i move away from myself
we can't quite hear you could you hold
them i know sorry i moved away from the
mic i was making a point slightly
ironically not a dig at intelligence
squared by the way which is how many
severely disabled people there are in
this room there are very good reasons
for it not being discussed in parliament
which is based on a false consensus the
most the people most immediately
affected severely disabled people but
the very people who are not going to
have a voice because they're very ill
debbie come back quickly on that and
then i'm going to say i think that is
completely wrong the majority of
disabled people like the majority of
able-bodied people support there being a
change in the law because we as disabled
people don't want to relinquish the
control we have other over our own lives
of course there are elements that we
will never have control over and
that's just life but those which we can
we need to and my
physical disability does not change my
ability to make decisions for myself
about myself and about my own life and i
resent anybody saying that i am
a poor person that somebody else has got
to protect and defend
disabled people want to be in control of
their own lives and we have a right to
have that same control where everybody
else has got this law does not affect
the disabled disproportionately
say briefly that in the house of lords
there are a number of uh disabled peers
uh and they are the strongest
opponents of attempts to legalize
uh assisted dying led by uh lady jane
campbell
i'm going to a point from the balcony
there yep
um i think that in these debates you
often get um a lot of pressure for the
law to be clarified
for it to be codified by by acts of
parliament but i think we have a very
long tradition in our law of law always
being interpreted um by the courts and
by the director of public prosecution
and sometimes the pressure to try and
clarify everything to the nth degree is
actually
a damaging
process to go through it removes
flexibility from the law
but that does leave one thing that does
concern me does that not put too much
power in the hands of one man i.e or
woman
is not in this case the the director of
public prosecutions so are we not in a
position where that one man now decides
who is prosecuting who is not um it's
so i i think the clarification of the
law ultimately might be a step backwards
but should there not be a wider process
about who decides who is prosecuted
under this more flexible position that
we currently have mary warnock too much
power in the hands of the dpp
well i think i agree i feel
anxious about that but
there is
an area
where i think the law could be more
flexible and i entirely agree that this
is one of the merits of the law but if
the law of homicide
were to be changed so that
there was no
automatic
mandatory life sentence
then i think things would be very much
better i think that if
it's a homicide trial
somebody had
uh was was prosecuted for
ending the life of somebody who was
terminally ill and who had wanted to end
her life
supposing this husband were prosecuted
then if the jury could say to the judge
we find that there are mitigating
circumstances here which would lift
the necessity of the life sentence then
i think this would make an enormous
difference and i believe that that might
be the way that the law should be
changed the tour changed the law of
homicide emily quick point on this um
just i think what the status quo where
we have this degree of clarity with the
um dpp having uh issued factors in favor
and against prosecution in some ways
it's a good thing though i i take the
point that sometimes a lack of clarity
can have positive effects but there are
two ways in which i think this is
problematic one is the status quo is
that we're exporting a sister suicide
switzerland and that doesn't seem to me
to be the right way to go about this the
second thing is if you can know at the
level of prosecution when somebody
should be treated as a criminal for
assisting a suicide
it doesn't seem to me beyond the balance
of possibility that you could know that
at the level of the definition of the
offence
alex carlisle is whispering to me he
wants to say two tiny sentences two tiny
sentences one i agree entirely with
baroness warnock the mandatory life
sentence should be removed i hope the
coalition will do it there's practically
no one in the house of lords who
believes it's justified and the answer
to the gentleman on in the balcony is
the dpp does not have too much power
because he's subject to judicial review
and is regularly the subject of actions
for judicial review so his decisions in
the end are controlled by the judges
okay i'm going to a point at the back
here and then i'm coming back up to the
balcony yeah
lord harris you spoke very movingly
about ubuntu and accompanying our loved
ones
to the end
you are speaking there for my late
mother who before her catastrophic
stroke at the age of 85 had signed a
living will and who after the stroke
repeatedly begged me to help her to die
and i know that no greater act of ubuntu
or whatever you like to call it no
greater act of love
um could have been
than helping her
um to have a dignified and peaceful
death so are you sure you're speaking
for everyone what what happened in the
end what
against all prognostications it took her
nearly six years to die and she was
lonely even though i was there
richard harris well i think i can i can
just simply respect
your experience and and suggest that
there rather there are other
uh instances i mean i think of my own
mother who also had a terrible stroke
and couldn't speak properly for the last
five or six
years of her life
um
and
it was it was terrible it was agonizing
but i couldn't say that there were no
blessings that came out of it
i couldn't say
that
would she have said that if she could
have done
well she had a huge will to live
i mean she was a great fighter she went
on fighting to the end paddy stone you
must see these cases every day of the
week i mean it's obviously it's always
very difficult to comment on
individual cases you know i obviously
everybody's heart goes out to your
individual experience here but i suppose
just at one level it does illustrate
slightly
that we're meant to be talking here
about legalizing assisted suicide for
the terminally ill and you know what you
just presented there was a case of
somebody who who lived for another six
years was this patient
terminally ill and i think that's the
problem
is that it's impossible to try to
regulate something that says it is just
for the term and ill once you start
introducing this it becomes
for anybody who's i mean most people who
suffer a stroke and survive are disabled
they're not terminally ill
point up in the balcony thank you three
quick points the first one i think
baroness warnock must have privileged
information that the rest of us doesn't
have when she says the natural
conclusion of compassion is that death
would be better than some cases of life
we don't know what it's going to be like
after death number one number two i
think people mostly said and i am speak
as a secular sinner on this poet
the secondly you said that uh most
people who are terminal would be like to
allow like to be allowed to die in peace
i would like to advocate for the
increase in hospice care for more people
rather than putting our energy into this
particular debate and thirdly what
concerns me is that there are three men
in the panel arguing as i would that
assisted suicide should not be legalized
and women arguing for it given our
relative longevity there are going to be
more single vulnerable inarticulate
women around who can't argue in the way
the honourable people do on the left and
my concern is that this argument can
very quickly become an euthanasia
argument against vulnerable women
[Applause]
mary warnock i think you better answer
first the point to you that that you
suggested that death is better in some
cases than life what do you know that
we don't know well
of course i don't do what death is like
except i i know it won't be like
anything but but um
i don't think
life is what is valuable life isn't the
kind of stuff
that is valuable in itself like gold or
platinum or something
there isn't such a thing as life except
life lived by somebody and if that
somebody hates
her life or is in absolute misery then
that life has no value for her
life itself
is an abstraction it's not anything
that's valuable but you and i and
everybody in this room is alive and i
hope
enjoying our life experiences but if
we are not
then
being alive
is not something to value in itself
debbie
is is assisted suicide a feminine issue
well it depends how many women are in
the room
but i think
that
on the question of the value of life
nobody has the right to place a value in
my life
other than me
i live it i can decide and my disability
is not an issue my disability
does not mean that i enjoy life less
or that i enjoy life more it's a fact of
who i am and i'm proud of who i am and
it's not my disability i'm proud of it's
my mind and jane campbell i'm sure will
say the same thing that it isn't that we
are able-bodied or disabled and the
majority of terminally ill people in
this country are not necessarily
disabled and i think the idea of turning
what we are talking about into an issue
about disability
is quite wrong
because our abilities are not based on
whether or not we are disabled
right i'm going to go to a point at the
back on my left followed by a point at
the back on my right sorry if it's going
backward a step but do the um against
people then actually think it's right
that nobody has yet been prosecuted for
taking relatives to switzerland
you're saying sorry so do the people who
are
against uh legalizing the assisted
suicide think that it's correct that
nobody has yet been prosecuted for
taking their relatives to switzerland
do you do you think it's right that no
one has as so far been prosecuted for
taking their relatives to switzerland i
think some 90 people or so have taken
people to switzerland and no action has
been taken against them which is exactly
of course what debbie had clarified from
the dpp
you're asking i am i think it's a matter
for the director of public prosecutions
to decide
you're being asked if you think it's
wrong that they haven't been well i
don't know the facts this is a serious
answer wait a minute i i don't know the
facts of the case
hang on hang on
i do not know the facts of a single case
that the director of public prosecutions
has had to look at
i have not looked at the files that the
director of public prosecutions has had
to look at
i believe i believe if i may answer the
question without being interrupted i
believe that there are cases in which it
may well be right for people to be
prosecuted and i expect actually rather
more people to be prosecuted than have
been in the past as a result of the
clarity that is being given to the law
as a result of debbie purdy's excellent
court action
you expect more people to be prosecuted
so i i i well if one were to you have to
take as your starting point when the
dpp's policy was put into place
and i believe that the dpp's policy has
given
a considerable amount of clarity to the
law
and that as a result if you read it you
will find that certain people are likely
to be prosecuted for example people who
have a substantial financial gain
or people who have put the person who
has died under any sort of pressure but
i'm afraid like everything in the
criminal law every case is different
it's a matter of evidence it was clear
before was it not that anyone who
assisted someone to commit suicide was
actually contravening the law yet 90
people have gone
to switzerland and have helped someone
commit suicide and they haven't been
prosecuted you're actually making a
sweeping generalization if i may say so
because i don't know what those 90
people did i don't know if as a matter
of law for example helping someone to
buy a ticket to go to switzerland is
assisting suicide as a matter of law i
rather doubt it in in the eyes of the
dpp none of them did anything wrong it
would seem well the dpp judges the cases
on the evidence you know what's wrong
with that quick point from emily here
just to say um there have been cases
where he set out his decision
in extraordinary detail and booking a
ticket does satisfy the evidential
burden for assisting so he said that
does um but there have been no cases
where the public interest has been so is
there anyone in the room who would like
to add a point at this moment to support
alex carlisle and his arguments just put
your hands down if you're doing the
opposite for a moment is there anyone
who would like to make a point on this
side
sorry we can't hear you can you can we
get a microphone to you is
hold on hold on hold on because the
people online won't hear you even if we
can are you asking for general arguments
in favor of that what they're arguing in
general are you arguing particularly the
arguments he's made
well
i think i'm asking for an argument that
supports this side well that would be uh
i can okay
okay
um
i think it would have been helped
actually in this debate had we had more
specific proposals from that side uh for
exactly how they would legalize assisted
suicide generally the argument in favor
of assisted suicide is for the oregon
model as i understand it the campaigns
for it in this country well in that case
if you are arguing for that and it would
be helpful if you would say if you are
then you really have to um argue why um
it would not fall into the problem that
dr stone has mentioned of where a right
to die soon becomes a duty to die it's
not just a matter uh for miss purdy and
people like her it's for those who are
much more vulnerable than miss purdy um
actually the oregon state public health
division brings out an annual report
every year since the legalization of
assisted suicide in oregon in
1998 13 of all the people who assisted
suicide uh did it because they felt
there would be a burden on their
families within 10 years 2007 this had
got more than triple to 44.9 percent of
people who are commissioning system
because they felt they were a burden is
that really a voluntary autonomous
decision debbie
the rates of people who use the law in
oregon
is around 100 a year
so
it's not like there's a mass number of
people who want to end their lives and a
lot of people
in oregon have the ability to then talk
to people talk to their family talk to
their friends talk to their physicians
about their decision to have an assisted
death and quite often the rates of
requesting and gaining assisted death
are lower than the rates of suicide in
other
other states because people are able to
explore
what other options are available to them
it is too late when somebody is dead to
discuss whether or not to prosecute the
person who assisted them we have to do
that discussion in advance of somebody
dying and the kind of tribunals that
terry pratchett talked about to explore
the opportunities that doctors can
alleviate pain that your social
situation can be changed that family
members have the ability to say you're
not a burden
that's what we need okay we're moving
towards a summing up but i promised
someone at the back there yes quick
point if you would um i'd just like to
um draw on something that dr stone said
and that's the distinction between
killing and letting die it's not
something that's really been discussed
between killing and killing and letting
die
um something that james rachel discusses
quite a lot so basically at the moment
it's okay for a doctor to say that they
are going to withhold treatment but it's
um it's not okay to say administer a
lethal injection to to produce the same
effect and to me this just seems like a
completely inadequate distinction both
legally and morally because not only are
you subjecting them to more suffering
but also surely if you've got a duty of
care you've got a duty of care and if
you're going to let them die then you're
you're killing them either way okay and
i'm going to take another point here
if you could bring the microphone
quickly down to this gentleman here
who's had his hand up for a very long
time gentlemen just at the back there
and then i'm going to call for some
summing up first i agree with the lady
who just asked the last question um but
for alex carlisle
you were saying there's about 90 cases
of people who've taken their relatives
to switzerland
um i think
and you haven't looked into them
and you're a lawyer and you're the joint
head of a public policy think tank
that's supposed to research assisted
suicide
shouldn't you have looked into them
you said you haven't read the files
well i think we've been around that one
so i think what i'll do is i'll call for
some i'll call for some summing up now
and uh ask you to vote while we do i'm
going to ask you to vote while we do it
it's slightly unfair because you don't
get to hear the summing up and i'm sorry
that we can't have any more points i'm
really sorry about that um but i guess
it's better than asking you to sit
around um with your stomachs rumbling so
the ushers will be coming around with
the ballot boxes if you could get your
votes ready ripping the tickets in half
let's have the summings up in the
reverse order richard harry's first
please
um well first let me just i may just
sort of state some fundamentals of
a christian moral approach to this
subject in order to try to dispel a
certain
uh
number of misconceptions the first of
all we're under no obligation to prolong
life as far as possible the 19th century
poet uh clef
thou shalt not kill but need not strive
officiously to keep alive and that's a
very good summary i think uh of a humane
christian approach to this there's no
obligation to go on prolonging life
secondly as paddy mentioned we have the
right the moral right
and the legal right to refuse burdensome
uh treatment
and the second point is in relation to
as it were uh killing and and simply
letting letting die it is fundamental to
christian moral theology as well as good
medical practice uh that it is entirely
right
to give somebody a dose of painkillers
to relieve their pain even though it may
have the effect of shortening their life
and there's a very profound moral
difference between that and deliberately
injecting a drug which will will kill
them and what i'd like to suggest is
that if one takes these considerations
into account together with advanced the
possibility of having an advanced
directive which was meant earlier on and
good palliative care there was
absolutely no need to change the law in
order to make it possible for people to
seek help and assisting dying thank you
very much mary warnock
i think that richard now and
during the of the discussion
some people do
um
rather
sanitize
what it's like dying
i don't think that for one thing
there are many people or
there are a lot of people who don't feel
that at the end of their life they're
going to be comforted by having a lot of
other people around them i think a lot
of us feel that as we get more and more
feeble and undignified we want to be
left alone to die
but secondly i really don't think
that the um
stuff about um
double effect and it being okay to give
someone a dose
that will kill them they will never have
to will still kill them but your
intention was to relieve that pain i
simply do not believe in the morality of
that antique argument
and i don't in any way i don't think
it's necessary because nowadays people
are much better at distinguishing
different drugs which actually sedate
people or kill them i would like to
argue in my own case that if i can't
stand living anymore i should be given
terminal sedation it wouldn't make any
difference to me whether i was dead or
terminally sedated but at least it would
be
relieve the contents of the doctors and
save me from suffering
paddy stone
[Applause]
[Music]
i think just uh briefly i would say that
um although palliative care
can
alleviate much of the fear and the
distress associated with dying i would
not stand here and say to you that it
will remove all of the demands for
assisted suicide i'm not that naive and
the main reason for that is that
patients choose
patients make autonomous decisions that
they want to end their life and no
amount of palliative care will actually
get rid of those few requests from the
few patients who want to choose the hour
and the day on which they die
my question to you is is that worth
changing the law to expose the large
number of vulnerable patients who i look
after on a daily basis to expose them to
increased risk of having their lives
shortened
that's the decision that's before you
debbie purdy
people have talked about the slippery
slope as if we are inevitably going to
roll down it
the law is a crampon that can be used to
stop that
if we have a law and i don't believe
it's beyond our
collective um you know ability to devise
a law that will provide the security and
the protection
that people want as well as providing
the relief and the security that people
need
and i think that
the only way we can do that is if
parliament gets
its head
up and starts looking at the issues and
stops leaving it to an unelected
official like the director of public
prosecutions i think he's done a
wonderful job in the guidelines but he
is an unelected um
he is an appointed official it's not his
role and it's not his right to make
legal
situations that the rest of us are bound
by we vote for our
mps to do that and they should do it
i think that and what we need is an open
discussion and i think
this kind of discussion is what is
valuable i don't believe that one side
has all the answers and i don't think
anybody has a monopoly on the truth i
think that has to be discussed and i
think the protection that is offered
is huge if we have a proper law which
discusses
the rights and wrongs the possibilities
not possibilities and allows and
encourages
doctors and people of the cloth and
social workers to be involved in that
decision-making process and family
that decision-making process when
somebody is alive and not leave it until
after they're dead
[Applause]
alex carla
four short points the first it has been
said repeatedly that the law is in a
mess the law is not in a mess the law is
clear the director of public
prosecutions has published a policy as
requested
and instructed by the supreme court and
in my view it is a proper part of our
common law system that there should be a
civilized exercise of discretion within
a clear law to decide whether it is in
the public interest on the evidence in
an individual case whether it should be
prosecuted
the second point is related to that
we've heard it said repeatedly
that a law can be devised to deal with
the problem that is raised by this
motion
but we've been there time and time again
we've had two debates we've actually had
three debates in the house of lords
we've had two votes
numerous attempts have been made to try
and devise a law and not one of those
attempts has produced a law that
compares with any any compares properly
with the certainty of the law as it is
so there is no alternative produced for
us debate to debate and none has been
produced today
third point
debbie purdy said very powerfully that
things have changed since 1961.
and she cited a number of examples i
would say to her that they have nothing
to do with the issue that we're dealing
with debbie and let's just think about
some things that may have something to
do with the issue
what's happened among other things since
the murder rate has increased
dr shipman has been convicted a medical
doctor
of killing a very large number of people
the staffordshire case occurred in which
a nurse was convicted of killing a
number of people
palliative medicine has developed a pace
doctors have greater skills and i think
paddy a wider range of drugs that they
can use in different ways
and a good death is therefore far more
possible in the face of a serious
illness than was the case in 1961
and the fourth point i want to make very
strongly because nobody has addressed it
at all in this debate i tried to mention
to mention it when i started
nobody has discussed the effect on the
person who is required to assist the
suicide
that person has a very great burden
placed upon them it's not just a legal
burden it's a moral burden and i think
we have to in a debate like this if
we're really going to reach an educated
and intelligent result debate the effect
on the person who actually is asked or
required to assist the suicide thank you
very much
finally as we wait for our result emily
jackson um two very brief points about
the difference between killing and
letting die which are our laura's
enshrined uh in at the moment one is the
point has been made if you're being fed
through a tube you have an absolute
right to insist that doctors do
something which will inevitably lead to
your death that makes the right to
medical help dependent on the morally
arbitrary presence of a peg tube people
with feeding tubes may be vulnerable and
they may believe that they're a burden
but they have the right to demand that
doctors do that the second thing i
wanted to say about the killing and
letting die distinction is that letting
die isn't always okay letting die can
sometimes be very wrong indeed indeed it
can sometimes amount to murder if you
imagine a
villainous racist
pediatric
nurse finding herself alone in an
intensive care ward who was to withdraw
the feeding tubes from all of the
non-white babies in that war that would
be murder the fact that she's letting
them die from their previous inability
to breathe doesn't excuse that action so
letting die can be wrong and i would say
the converse is true causing death can
sometimes be the right thing to do in
terms of what a law would would include
i would have a palliative care filter a
social support filter compulsory
psychiatric assessment unbearable
suffering that can't be relieved it's
not going to be easy to draft an
effective assisted dying law but i think
we owe it to the people who do suffer
unbearably to try
[Applause]
well we're we're still awaiting the
result it's obviously a closer run thing
than the entry pole anyway so maybe
gentlemen on the left you've had a deal
of effect this evening just while we're
waiting for it
what hasn't come up this evening it
strikes me is the terminology and i
wonder richard harris if you would care
to
speak to that uh you know the point is
that
assisted suicide is quite a quite an
emotional quite a a nasty term really
surely voluntary euthanasia is a better
term more assisted dying as well
euthanasia i take
i mean these are slippery terms they can
be defined in different ways uh i mean
euthanasia i take it is when the doctor
administers the drug and euthanasia can
either be voluntary or involuntary to
either can be the result of request or
as in nazi germany because the
government wanted it assisted dying i
think as we have it in the oregon model
is that the person who's assisted who
wants to die administers the drug
themselves they get it from the doctor
but they admit it administer it
themselves that's how i make the
distinction but the word suicide is is
implies a kind of confusion and despair
whereas assisted suicide presumably is
done in faith well the word suicide of
course is a very emotive term um and
because
suicide has been associated with being a
very
severe
criminal act and suicides until the 19th
century were buried at the crossroads
and so on i think people quite rightly
have moved away to less emotive language
so we talk about assisted dying or
euthanasia either voluntary or
involuntary and i think that's probably
uh helpful and it is probably uh
better to use the the
confine the word suicide to other
instances where it is it is obvious that
a person uh has committed suicide for
for various reasons which are
non-medical and are not terminal and so
on what's your preferred option debbie
as of terminology i prefer to call
assisted dying because the one thing you
can absolutely guarantee apart from
taxes
is that none of us is getting out of
here alive
and
if you are in unbearable pain whether
that pain is physical or emotional
if you ask for assistance to end your
life
that is
assisted dying i think that
terminology is quite
different
and i would say that
the fact that i'm not terminally ill
does not mean that my life will
necessarily
not become unbearable but it might not
be and that's why i think we should make
sure that
we have proper laws that are in place
but there is another point about
assisted suicide
which is
that there are some people
who
simply can't physically can't commit
suicide can't take the drug themselves
and therefore if i'm going to change the
law
and allow some people to be assisted in
dying one would have to make
accommodation for the diane blood people
who simply couldn't physically
take the stuff themselves and that would
be grossly unfair if that kind of person
were left out of the permissiveness of
the law
so i prefer just to die on the whole
so we have a result and that is that
before the debate in favor of the motion
that assisted suicide should be made
legal were 408 people in the room after
the debate it's 406 people
well done
against were 110
now against big swing 208
and the don't knows have moved from 119
to 34 so some people formed a view this
evening it's all been worthwhile
[Applause]
you